we might not learn the truth of what
happened inside Manhattan's Metropolitan
Correctional Center until the
investigations are over that hasn't
stopped the speculation and anger
swirling that such a high profile inmate
as Jeffrey Epstein was able to
apparently take his own life
weeks after attempting suicide has
raised questions about how he was being
monitored I would want updates on him
multiple times a day and if my chief
psychologist a program coordinator was
contemplating taking the inmate off
suicide I would certainly expect that
issue to be discussed among the
facilities executive staff this is a
huge black eye on the US Department of
Justice and more specifically the Bureau
of Prisons there's anger to that Epstein
facing charges of the sex trafficking of
underage girls will not now face his
accusers in court not least from
Democrats running for president the
system broke down here he should have
been held for trial and his victims
should have had a chance to testify
against him and in a letter to the
Attorney General Republican senator Ben
Sasse wrote the Department of Justice
failed and today Jeffrey Epstein's
co-conspirators think they might have
just gotten one last sweetheart deal
every single person in the Justice
Department from your main justice
headquarters staff all the way to the
night shift jailer knew that this man
was a suicide risk and that his dark
secrets
couldn't be allowed to die with him
prosecutors say the investigations will
continue into a man who counted the
likes of Bill Clinton and Donald Trump
as friends the case has threatened to
implicate prominent names from the
worlds of business and politics among
them his friend the Duke of York in
court documents released in the u.s. in
the last few days the Prince was accused
of inappropriate behavior towards two
women he was with the Queen at Balmoral
this weekend Buckingham Palace says any
suggestion of impropriety with underage
minors is categorically untrue the
conspiracy theories surrounding
Epstein's death have been fueled even by
presidential retweet of accusations
against the Clintons it is filling the
void for American
wondering how a man facing so many
questions could be allowed to escape
providing the answers Gregg Milam Sky
News Los Angeles